[Music]
greetings [ __ ] uncle Joey here
amongst the woman that's checking in
with you [ __ ] making sure your
Friday is beautiful tremendous and you
have plenty going on you know I'm saying
I'm out of [ __ ] words
oh I know it's it's Friday I'm ready a
sling dick and hit a [ __ ] on the
head with a gun you follow me we'll
[ __ ] what three weeks away from
shooting special October 15th and I said
I'm very happy you understand we've got
some tremendous we'd still able to tell
Linda Larry which I'm going to the store
at 10:01 to [ __ ] make my weekly
pickup of debt I got some [ __ ] og
debt and I still got some [ __ ]
presidential from the Russians down
there at sunset over you like Joey what
the [ __ ] you've been I've been busy
right you know mate though I'm an old
man I'm trying to put the pieces
together I have to get it at the podcast
I'm writing a book I'm writing a [ __ ]
special I'm hanging out with my [ __ ]
peeps you know and isn't trying to stay
healthy my back's [ __ ] up but I went
to acupuncture yesterday she cooked that
[ __ ] she put needles all over me
in fact this old Chinese chick put me up
in the [ __ ] air upside down and blew
a dark [ __ ] acupuncture needle at the
bottom of my boss side I'm happy I
haven't been this happy in years I
suggest you do the same find yourself
some little [ __ ] Asian put yourself
upside down and have it just blow a dart
right into your [ __ ] nut sack it's
over after that but Joey what's with the
[ __ ] dodging in that sack when we're
gonna spark well let this [ __ ] herb
man freak
say no more
now that's the way I like it God's up
they should call this case EOG weed I'm
happy I'm hearing that's the way we cuz
my back but if everything goes as
planned I should be in there [ __ ]
doing hip escapes on [ __ ] Sunday
cutting it down I've been sticking to my
diet and everything is cool see old sow
the special is [ __ ] in 45 minutes in
I need to put 15 minutes together for
you in three weeks to rock your
[ __ ] world baby way tonight I'm
in Mountain View California by Sam Cooke
Jim Jeffries Sebastian Maniscalco but
hey I'm in the undercard but I ain't
[ __ ] complaining young Sam oh my
Frankie I got the garden I'm in the
undercard me Thomson Bora and I think it
I'm very happy I'm back in my hotel room
by 8:15 I wash my little monkey and I'm
an original [ __ ] Jose on the corner
there you go eating the [ __ ] little 8
ounce steak with some spaghetti on this
side meatless you follow me that's how I
do it I got my day planner afternoon my
daughter I take the girls out to [ __ ]
lunch and then it's at the Irvine
whatever and then Sunday I shoot over
the [ __ ] Phoenix with you
[ __ ] I'm the oddball of Phoenix
why I miss you people I haven't been to
Phoenix or [ __ ] yeah I'll be there
full-time in January for a [ __ ] week
at the Tempe improv but for now Joey
what's with the [ __ ] ear beaten I know
I know sometimes I get emotional I
smoked some weed it's got some in the
damn it I lose my [ __ ] mind
I'm sorry never again let's just I gotta
get you [ __ ] ready for the
weekend we'll be saying him alright to
see you
the Larry og is done it's got low THC
crystals in here yo asthma you always
want to get this this is the real
[ __ ] death of life here then we're
gonna finish this [ __ ] another [ __ ] I
had this is tremenda dis Rica has some
good [ __ ] we you know salmon if it
wasn't for me getting up to [ __ ] pee
in the middle of my sleeping [ __ ]
mummy all he had was reptiles on my head
didn't you see me - [ __ ] signal fire
nicey-nice my [ __ ] family it's like
Thanksgiving is like Thanksgiving every
day with us just this little church
family we have together instead eat and
Toki we smoked a ball we exchanged some
[ __ ] past plum pleasantries and you
move on with you [ __ ] there he wants
to watch the Cowboys out
none like a people none like I don't
give a [ __ ] on me pills you take your a
deep deep pills you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] this diet depression this is it
this is a one pure war there's some CB
deal a couple [ __ ] push-ups and you're
back you don't saying you people I'm not
feeling that what the [ __ ] was born I
can't focus on smoke some of this [ __ ]
focused and I know but this and your
back is some same so we did a bowl of
[ __ ] Larry we did a bowl of the
heroin now we have the One Bowl or the
[ __ ] presidential I don't let you
guys go okay I don't want to take up
your whole day
get together with my favorite [ __ ]
people in the world smoke a bowl like a
[ __ ] civilian and go on with your
days it's not harming now you wanna
throw me in [ __ ] jail throw me a
[ __ ] jail for what we're doing this
getting together and [ __ ] motivating
one another maybe you're feeling a
little gloomy today I'm saying maybe
mama input calling the [ __ ] Stu if
you see what I'm saying you wake up or
[ __ ] up today uncle Joey comes in some
ways that way [ __ ] up and you're
knocked on the door no Joey let me
[ __ ] jump up and down see what's the
same difference be it's the same
difference
remember one thing you could be rich
poor [ __ ] [ __ ]
it don't matter what but the [ __ ]
main goal today is to make somebody's
day maybe they tell somebody good
morning maybe the tap on the shoulder
maybe to tell that [ __ ] do with the
way he's looking better than at the end
I'm saying a fat [ __ ] like me look Joey
you lost some weight
who gives a [ __ ] making somebody's day
is the best welcome
I make my daughter's teacher - yeah go
ahead - they look very nice as if you
know what will you pick it up [ __ ]
young kids on the weekend her face
turned purple the [ __ ] it I made her
dead that's the most important thing
somebody's down you can find our bill
who's better than you that's what it's
all about no Friday it's making
somebody's day are you gonna go
you just got here [ __ ] you
and at least we got that you could tell
you what is you know I just did a
[ __ ] ball with Joey
we talked would you talk to Porter [ __ ]
knows we're smoking reefer
so you got you know you got I just want
you to know I'm just an old fat [ __ ]
with fellas
what a [ __ ] I love him but I'm
telling you this is the way to do it
nice now you go out into the world and
you get home at night which is the most
important thing when you leave is to
[ __ ] get home at night in one piece
okay that's what I'm trying to do keep
your [ __ ] eyes off the phone today
look around for these creepy
[ __ ] and I said do the best you
can be me I'm gonna snow some dope yeah
I've got my rights and jokes today and
then get on a [ __ ] plane
I'll see you concept is tonight at home
with them [ __ ]
I forgot how are you spat you smoke you
get me high and then you gonna ask me
[ __ ] questions what type of people
you
the church is ready for you too
Sebastian
weather was not Monday my buddy there we
read we're ready for you so get your
[ __ ] together uncle Joey loves you we
have a nice little tape tape right this
is good enough for me
rub your [ __ ] feet and bring your
Danish that's never gonna happen
beside that I love you stay black you
don't give a [ __ ] what they think you
don't saying today you wake up your
plant you [ __ ] flag in somebody's ass
if you ain't doing that you try again
tomorrow
don't forget the smoke brief and do your
[ __ ] push-ups all right I love you
got serviced
stay black without you guys I have
nothing